caleb smith in the month of june is
starting to make a statement that he's a
guy that you can count on in his six
starts he's pitched to an era under
three
giving up only 20 base hits in 31 in the
third
and a fast ball in the fish that's
blooped into shallow center
it's falling and in there base head
slater muscled it over the infield and
gets the first hit of the game
and a runner in scoring position so two
down and here is buster posey
three-two to posey and posey lines that
one over the shortstop into left field
and that's going to put the giants ahead
i don't think it was a bad pitch but
buster posey beat it it's one nothing
giants
and as we always say ownage is ownage
i think in the end he opted for an
off-speed pitch yeah that's a change-up
hit it right off the end of the bat but
those are the kind of hits you get
against the guy that
they yell so two hits in the inning a
run now and here comes
darren rough darren ruff rips the first
pitch toward the gap in left center
and now we'll see if posey can keep
chugging he's to third pavement smith
scoops it up buster posey all the way
from first is gonna score
two-nothing giants trying to go on the
back
side with a little bit of a cutter it
just kind of drifts middle in
and i got to believe with the reputation
that caleb smith has ruff was looking
that way
because he jumped all over it finds a
gap and with a two out jump an easy
score for posey
so the giants have a couple of runs home
here in the first inning and anthony de
slofani ready to make
his 17th start of the year and take a
look at what diesel funny has done in 16
starts 8-3
2.91 era those are all-star worthy
numbers
that's a good slider strike three call
for pitch walk
and there's the one on base runners as
durable cabrera has been about their
hottest hit around and ladies up to 251
on the year now
the pitch and the curveball ground to
the second solano's got it over the
second one
and the relay back to first to a double
play
four to six to three an inning ending
double play and we head to the second
so solano retired to start the onion
there's jalen davis
got that fastball in there for strike
three two outs in the second
we've got some big time pop 35 home runs
among three different minor league stops
in the 2019 season
but they catch him guessing wrong right
there fastball inner third of the play
swing of the miss east lafanni down on
strikes back to back case to win the
second for
caleb smith that's two ounce on three
pitches for anthony diesclefani
and now the banner is josh there's a
ground ball right to short the stroud
has got it the throw to first
inning over three up and three down a
very quick inning there for
decephana we go to the third austin
slater got a single that was his first
at-bat after his
booming home run that proved to be the
game-winner last night
austin slater might have done it again
he launched that one
eamonn for the same spot wow holy smokes
for now 467
108 miles an hour they throw a change up
up there and unloads
and everybody in this ballpark knew it
was gone just a matter of how far gone
it was
wow a second slater home run in his many
games
so one down here is nick ahmed swing of
the miss he struck him out
devastating slider that broke just off
the outside at the last moment
and two men are gone anthony had retired
six in a row but somehow with two outs
the base is empty
and he walks the picture second base on
ball for diesel fighting the banner will
be josh van meter another 2-2
and he hit that one on one hop to second
good pitch from discovany and no problem
with the walk
to the pitcher t-back's looking for a
hit they're behind three-nothing fourth
inning now astruebel cabrera
that is a swinging strike three 95 mile
an hour heat
right above the hands perfect pitch two
and two the count to christian walker
yaz has plenty of room
and the inning is over three up three
down that's four
hitless innings in the books for d
sclafani oh we go bottom of the fifth
inning three nothing giants of the
diabetes still looking for that first
hit of the night david smith will lead
it off against dee slefani
there's a ball into center and it's a
kind of slider he couldn't get there in
time here's the dieback's first hit of
the night a base hit by pavement smith
josh reddick now is
rough to estrada back to diesel
double play the hard way jiren ruff
cutting over to his right made a nice
play and then made the quick feed
and then tyro estrada very niptilly
around the bag three nothing cairo
estrada will lead off to san francisco
sixth against caleb smith
caleb has set down all nine he's faced
since that slater homer
and he set down ten straight that
strikeout number five
and that is a walk for posey with two
down that gives darren ruff a chance
that ball is hit high and deep and
goodbye wow
a laser beam and almost under the
overhang of the second deck
a two run homer and the giants have a
five to nothing lead
that gives ruff three rbis in the game
here we go to the bottom of sixth inning
ahmed will lead things up
ahmed down on strikes three pitches and
out
beautiful cut fastball and now the
batter will be don varsio
oh ouch oh boy
that may have hit him on the fingertips
of the glove square on and that's like
getting your finger caught in the car
door
foul tip and i think it just got right
on the wrong spot on the
the like the base of the thumb probably
just sent a
shock of pain up posey's hand and
forearm
buster gets the mitt back on and says
he's all right the account
on varsha was folded three and two
and struck it out and that didn't look
good the way buster caught that one
yeah he just looked over it he's done
and he'll be getting some x-rays so he
took that 95 mile an hour fastball and
he gave the sign to gabe kepler that
he's
he's done as drill boats perched at
second base with the two base hit third
into the night for the d-backs
two outs after the double and now it's
going to take something from reddick
that's the basin into center here comes
cabrera
here's the throw it's offline reddick
into second
and they got him the run-ditch score
on the rbi hit by reddick the giants
have anthony d schlafani back to the
mound now with a five-to-one lead
swing and a miss and he did swing at
that one the played um fire
ray act signaling that it was foul tip
but into the glove of curt casalli
here is andre lafitte god eduardo
escobar
national league star
it's that one to left levon wade just in
the game and he tracks it down nice play
mott wade junior impressed d schlafani
with that catch
well look who's still on the mound how
about that and here's the pitch to ask
druba with one on one out
got him boy break the ball with some
fuzz on it i mean
he wants this complete game as walker
steps in
this is out to right that's going to get
down it'll get peralta home
[Music]
is stremski able to cut it off it's an
rbi knock for christian walker
don't go anywhere it's five to two and
that's going to be it for anthony de
santi there'll be no complete game
tonight
so tyler rogers comes in to try to get
the save for the giants so that sets up
the possible tying run of the game
and it's a veteran 34 year old josh
redick
reddick on the ground to second base
solano throws him out
and the game is over